PRAJAKTA DAMLE:
Welcome, everybody,
and thank you for
being here today.
My name is Prajakta Damle,
and I lead product management
for Dataplex at Google Cloud.
And joining me
today is John Allen,
head of data and
analytics product
strategy at Deutsche Bank.
John has been with Deutsche
Bank for over 9 years,
building their data platforms,
and enabling and championing
big data and data science
within the organization.
Welcome, John, and thank
you for your partnership,
as well as for being here today
to share Deutsche Bank's data
journey with us.
JOHN ALLEN: Well,
thanks for inviting me.
It's great to be
here with you today.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE: Likewise.
So let's get started.
Let's take a look at the
enterprise data landscape,
which as many of
you know is diverse
and becoming increasingly
distributed with data that
is stored in data lakes, data
warehouses, specialized data
marts, and databases, not
only on GCP but on prem,
as well as in other clouds.
Now, each one of
these systems have
their own way of handling
metadata, security,
and governance.
So on one hand, while the data
is becoming more distributed,
the number of users within an
organization that need access,
self-service access to this data
in the tools of their choice
is also growing.
And as a result,
companies often find
it challenging to
consistently manage and govern
their data while making
this data universally
discoverable and accessible
to the data consumers.
Honestly, it's an
operational nightmare
that often results in
data silos and impacts
the overall analytics agility
of most organizations.
If you look at the data, 67%
of the data that is produced
is actually never analyzed.
And 68% of the companies
are unable to realize
any tangible, measurable
value from their data.
What is even more
surprising is that only 16%
of the data consumers
that have access to data
actually trust the data
that they have access to.
And this is exactly
why we built Dataplex--
an intelligent data fabric that
unifies your distributed data
to help automate data management
and power analytics at scale.
So what does that actually mean?
So let's double-click
a little bit.
Dataplex is built from ground up
for distributed data, requiring
you to not move your data
or duplicate your data.
At the foundation of
Dataplex is its ability
to logically represent data
and unify data from a metadata
perspective regardless of
where this data is stored.
We have focused on three
key areas of value--
intelligent, AI-driven
data management;
centralized security
and governance;
and an integrated
analytics experience
bringing together both GCP
native and open-source tools.
All of these areas
are tightly integrated
in a task-centric
experience, helping
you build a flexible
data platform
and making this data
accessible to your end users,
while ensuring that your
policies and best practices
can be consistently enforced.
Now, this is a
vision for Dataplex.
We are starting out by unifying
the data that our customers use
for analytics on GCP
before extending it
to other sources outside of GCP.
Taking a closer look at that
task-centric experience,
we've built an experience
that focuses on the operations
that you need to undertake on
your data on a daily basis,
starting from
curating and managing
that data to monitoring,
securing, analyzing this data.
We have built key integrations
with existing products,
such as BigQuery, Dataproc,
Google Cloud Storage, Data
Fusion, Dataflow, Data
Catalog, and others
to really bring together
that single pane of glass
that you can use to curate,
manage, monitor, secure,
and analyze your data.
With Dataplex, you can
really organize your data
in a way that is meaningful
for your business
around different domains based
on how this data is produced
and owned or how
this data is used,
instead of where
this data is stored.
You can define
standardized policies
around access control, data
quality, data classification,
and lifecycle management.
And you can leverage the
built-in data intelligence
and metadata propagation
capabilities of Dataplex
to get out-of-box
access to this data
from a variety of
tools, both GCP
native as well as open source.
We have a number
of customers who
have been our early
adopters using Dataplex.
And these customers come from
various different industry
verticals as well
as geographies.
And they're using Dataplex
as a foundational component
of their data platform
and seeing value
in having this unified data
fabric to manage and govern
their distributed data.
And today, I'm really
happy to have John
here with us, who is going
to talk about how he sees
the value of data in the overall
strategy at Deutsche Bank,
his vision for the data
strategy, and the role
that Dataplex plays in
realizing that vision.
So welcome, John.
We are super excited
to have you here.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about yourself first and
then a little bit more
about Deutsche Bank and
how you use data today?
JOHN ALLEN: Sure.
Well, thanks again.
It's great to be here.
So I work within Deutsche
Bank's chief data office,
which is part of our Technology
and Data and Innovation
Division.
And our goal is really to enable
the secure supply, preparation,
and analysis of data across
the entire organization.
Now in my role looking
at product strategy,
I spend a lot of my time
working with the business teams
and technology vendors
to ensure that we
have the right roadmaps in place
to deliver those capabilities.
Deutsche Bank is the
leading German bank.
We have 84,000 employees
and operate just
under 1,900 branches, with
offices in over 50 countries.
The bank comprises of four
client-centric divisions--
a corporate bank, a private
bank, an investment bank,
and an asset manager, DWS,
which Deutsche Bank maintains
a significant stake in.
Now, being a global
bank, we rely
upon a very complex global
technology estate comprising
of tens of thousands
of machines,
thousands of
applications, and hundreds
of operational and
analytical data stores.
Our total data footprint is
in excess of 100 petabytes.
And we use that data for
a wonderfully diverse set
of use cases.
I'm trying to think of some.
In terms of our--
some of the more interesting
ones, our front office team
use data to drive
real-time analysis
and low latency
algorithmic trading,
and allows our product
managers to develop highly
personalized client offerings.
In the middle and
back office, we
leverage big data processing
to help manage risk
and to prevent fraud.
And like any business, we rely
upon highly accurate and timely
financial data to serve
regulatory and financial
reporting requirements.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE: You operate
in such a global market.
And the complexities of
operations that you just
mentioned across different
businesses within the bank,
it's quite interesting.
What role does data
play at Deutsche Bank?
And what has your journey
with data been like so far?
JOHN ALLEN: Well, I agree.
I mean, fundamentally
we're a data business.
And data is the
digital manifestation
of our clients, their
transactions, relationships,
and our internal processes.
However, we didn't always view
ourselves as a data business.
Instead, we had a more
application-centric mindset,
which saw data is more of a
side effect of that application
processing.
We locked data away
in disparate silos
with inconsistent
taxonomies and formats,
and a lack of clear ownership
and an over-reliance
on bilateral
point-to-point data feeds.
So to address this, we
established a long-term plan,
our data strategy, to
improve the availability
of high quality data organized
around a set of consistent data
models and golden sources,
to uplift skills in data
and increase understanding
of data problems
across the entire organization.
And we set out to enable modern
analytics, such as big data
and machine learning.
The transformation took
sustained investments
over many years and was
executed in an environment
of ever-changing regulations.
Just as an aside,
last year, there
were over 6,000
pages of new rules
that we needed to examine
to understand their impact
on that data landscape.
Today, we are a much more
data-centric organization,
which actively
manages and improves
its data as part of the
normal day-to-day operations.
We operate an
integrated ecosystem
of analytics platforms.
And we have the
key trusted sources
of high quality business
data needed to drive
intelligent decision making.
I know you asked for successes.
And I think, frankly, there
are too many to mention.
But from my personal
perspective,
I think the work
the private bank has
done creating new
personalized offerings
for our retail clients through
the application of machine
learning is especially
cool, as is the big data
processing that our risk teams
use to allow us to be much more
efficient with our capital.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE: It's
quite interesting
to hear how you have
made this transition,
or the bank has
made this transition
from an application-centric
view to a data-centric view
in an industry that is so highly
regulated with, as you just
mentioned, changing regulations
and compliance rules.
So what have been your top
learnings and challenges
so far?
JOHN ALLEN: Well, for me some of
the most significant learnings
relate to governance, ownership,
and how we as an organization
think about data--
our data culture, if you will.
Foremost for me, data needs
to be treated as a first class
citizen within the enterprise
if it is to be used and reused
effectively.
It must be seen as an
asset in its own right.
Also, finding the right
balance between security
and stability,
coupled with agility
to deliver analytics and
help customers, is difficult.
Maintaining distinctly separate
operational and analytical
organizations fails to
deliver analytical stability
and efficiency.
What I mean there is this
is when those teams do not
use and thus value each
other's representations of what
is, in essence, the same data.
Metadata is also a critical
foundation for effective data
management and data governance.
However, building
and maintaining
a unified repository of
high quality metadata
is a significant challenge in
traditional IT environments.
And finally, I think while
centralization of data
can seem like an attractive
approach to achieving
consistency and standards and
the application of policies,
it very often leads
to bottlenecks
that inhibit business agility.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE: So given
these learnings, especially
learnings around how to
build trust in data, how
to avoid data duplication,
how to put metadata
at the center and foundation
of your data platform,
could you share with us what is
your short-term and long-term
data strategy for the bank?
JOHN ALLEN: Yeah, I'd love to.
Well, our goal is to democratize
the use of data and analytics
by making it a secure
and frictionless
self-service experience.
Only then will we
be able to make
data accessible to
everyone and not
just the data experts
within the organization.
We intend to do
this by investing
in the automation of
controls and policies,
which along with high quality
metadata, technical, business,
and contextual metadata,
will allow us to build a data
control plane that
ensures that our data is
easy to find and access,
yet always remains secure
wherever it is used.
Now, currently we're
completing our transition
to managing data as an asset,
changing our IT processes
to allow data to thrive outside
of those owning applications
we traditionally had.
We're also converging
on common approaches
to data sharing and
data re-use, which
use streamlined data
governance processes,
a new unified
repository of metadata,
and automation to make
our data more accessible.
To help our engineering
teams, we're
also developing standard
reference architectures
for common data problems,
such as streaming and batch
analytics, and machine
learning in GCP.
And finally, we're
investing in our people
with training in Cloud and
agile data best practices.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE: So speaking
of cloud and your partnership
with Google Cloud, how
has Google Cloud helped
you realize your data vision?
JOHN ALLEN: Well, the
partnership with Google
has given us a fantastic base
to build our future banking
services on.
Technologies such as GCS,
BigQuery, Dataflow, Dataproc
are much more powerful
and easy to use than our
on premise equivalents.
Likewise, Cloud SQL, Datastore,
GCE, App Engine, and Pub/Sub
for transactional systems.
However, for me
what's really exciting
is the advancements in machine
learning that Vertex AI
and BigQuery ML can bring.
But that's not to say
it's all plain sailing.
There is still a lot of work
to integrate and assemble
these products into
effective business solutions.
And this is especially true in
a risk averse, highly regulated
industry such as ours.
Speaking frankly, there is
still quite a gap to close.
I think this is an area where
we see the partnership being
especially beneficial.
So Google understands
this complexity.
And together we are
developing approaches
to solve these
problems in the Cloud.
In fact, we are already
seeing some exciting product
developments from Google.
A good example of that
is indeed Dataplex.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE:
Your team has been
an early adopter of Dataplex.
And your close partnership
is extremely valuable for us
as you provide us guidance
on product direction.
I would love to
hear more about how
you see Dataplex fit in
your overall data strategy,
how Dataplex is helping you
with some of the data challenges
that you mentioned early on.
JOHN ALLEN: Yeah, absolutely.
Well, we are looking to
use Dataplex to give us
a way of organizing our data
around our core business
and data concepts,
such as global markets
data, payments
data, customer data,
without having to copy that data
from its originating mastering
application projects.
Dataplex's lakes and zones
give us an elegant way to group
our data assets depending upon
their type, their quality,
or their stage in
their data lifecycle.
And we're experimenting
with the designs
for operating this at
an enterprise level.
These zones are very
important concept for us.
In fact, we implemented
something similar in our
on premise data lake.
However with Dataplex, we can
take this to the next level,
realizing a much more
federated system,
employing a type of data mesh
architecture, if you will,
where data remains in
situ, owned and governed
by its originators,
yet still part
of a unified platform
maintained by Dataplex
and integrated with a set
of leading analytical tools.
I think GCP's Data Catalog also
gives us amazing capabilities.
It gives us visibility of key
organizational data assets.
But with Dataplex, we
can go a step further
and extend the Data Catalog
with the automated discovery
and classification of
semi-structured and
unstructured data.
Now ensuring our data is secure
is of paramount importance.
And we're investing heavily
in the automation of controls
and embedding those controls
into our infrastructure as code
and as policies.
However, today we still need
to develop those controls
for each data service we use.
We also need to find a
way of enforcing them
through infrastructure
as code templates
and tools such as Terraform.
This adds complexity.
With Dataplex, we
have the potential
to develop these controls once
for the lake, zone, and assets,
and let Dataplex do the
hard work of applying them
to the different
underlying technologies.
And the plans Dataplex has for
extending this policy driven
approach to include
data governance, data
management, and data quality
tasks is particularly exciting.
We can imagine a world where we
assess, transform, and promote
our high quality data
based upon policies
and not hand coded data
pipelines, allowing
us to focus more on the
value creating tasks
and less on maintaining
boilerplate data integration.
So in summary, I think we
see BigQuery for analytics
and Dataplex for data management
as cornerstones of our vision
for enabling a secure
and frictionless data
experience in the cloud.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE: Well,
thank you, John.
Thank you for sharing your
insights and perspective
with us today.
JOHN ALLEN: Your welcome.
PRAJAKTA DAMLE:
And also, thank you
to you and your team for
your continued partnership.
So as you heard
John just outline,
Dataplex helps enterprises
unlock the freedom of choice
by providing them
the flexibility
to keep data where they see fit
and to use the tools that they
need to run analysis
within their organization.
Dataplex provides a way to
enable consistent controls
across enterprise data landscape
that is inherently distributed.
And finally, with
Dataplex our customers
can leverage the built-in
data intelligence
to automate many of
the common data tasks
around data management
and governance
across their data estate.
So that's all that
we have today.
If you would like to
learn more about Dataplex,
do check our website.
And thank you, everyone,
for your time today
and for attending
this session on how
Dataplex helps enterprises
break down their data silos.
Thanks again.
JOHN ALLEN: Thanks.